knock knock with the trailer in second
trailer for
now before all those comments come in
going oh i thought john would be with
you yeah you know i thought it'd be here
too we we
agreed to meet up at this time and i
have no idea where the guy is i'm
assuming he's still asleep
so what i'm going to ask is that
everyone follow him on social media
reign carnage in the comments or his
dms let him know how unprofessional of a
reactor he is doesn't he know you're not
supposed to sleep
[Music]
all i ever wanted in this world is
carnage
already
i must eat
please don't mind me it's mine
it's yours and it's yours
it's mine
[Music]
oh
oh interesting
oh
love anne
right now
wow
awesome awesome
[Laughter]
that's great that's great i'm so excited
for this movie well right that was a
really awesome trailer i
i love that one quite a bit obviously
there's going to be channels more like
you know new rock stars and heavy
spoilers and screen crush we're going to
go frame by frame here and break
every single detail down but you know
i'll just talk about everything that
really stood out to me here i mean you
get this really cool
shot of shriek shriek looks like she's
doing one of her moments where she's
manipulating
sound yeah this is more like of a
theatrical trailer and like the first
one
felt like a theatrical trailer but you
get more details here than you did in
the last one
for example just right there with cletus
visiting
or eddie brock visiting cletus cletus
getting in his hand and biting down into
him getting a taste for it showing how
he gets a symbiote within him that was a
little bit like already you were like no
that cannibalistic
side of him is showcased right there in
that scene
you get the idea of man when you combine
a symbiote
symbiote who already loves to have the
taste of human flesh already loves to
eat humans with a human who already
likes to have the taste of humans you
know you're gonna get
a very villainous character and a very
sadistic one at that
breakout at ravencroft that looks like a
very very
awesome scene there are some times where
the cgi looked a tad bit off
but for the most part it still looked
great it was still very wicked i hope
it even plays a lot more violent and
menacing and has
more of an oomph because already the
trailer was pretty awesome but here i
was very much like oh that's gonna be a
really sick scene i'm hoping to have a
let it ooze
when watching that moment i liked how
this trailer establishes
is you have like eddie brock who wants
to do the right thing dude the good
thing because he already has
a relationship sort of with uh cletus
cassidy because you know of course
cletus lets
eddie brock interview him and is like
the only one who's been able to get some
like stories
out of cletus so he's already got a
personal motive to go
up against him so i like that setup here
much more than the first venom movie
where
cletus and eddie there's it's gonna feel
like a little bit more
of a personal antagonist versus
protagonist situation due to the fact
that cletus and eddie knew each other
beforehand but when it comes time to
actually fighting carnage i really love
that moment because
earlier in the trailer you got venom
who's like we should be snacking on bad
guys
i'm a pricker i must eat his motivation
it is not to be like
i want to do the right thing i want to
take on this carnage venom saying that
and so eddie has to convince him to have
some deal struck
if you come out and we fight him i'll
let you eat whoever you want
you could have whoever you want to eat
at this moment so i don't know if that's
actually going to land in a territory of
after they defeat
carnage suddenly he's like fine we had a
deal you can eat whomever you want
i don't think it's gonna go down that
path so i'm kind of wondering what the
arc for venom
will be like if he'll have a greater
motive than just
feeling like he has the freedom to eat
whomever he wants they had the joke here
at the end here about you know
couples counseling so maybe eddie and
venom they're learning how to make
sacrifices and compromises
with one another as they're having this
budding relationship forming that from
the outside looking in
feels a bit romantic to some people so
we have
anne who i feel like is barely gonna be
in this movie
you know i know that was a part of the
first film that wasn't exactly beloved
much as michelle williams is an amazing
actress i don't think like people really
cared for just the character
in here i don't think it's her fault and
the trailers don't seem to be doing
anything that are really
allowing you to go yeah eddie go go get
her ready
go go get her she's getting married and
then they're having to sit down here
and maybe it'll be that cliche where in
the end she does leave is actually you
know funny enough
it kind of makes you think of spider-man
2 about spider-man 2
mj was gonna get married in that but by
the end of it she she'd leave if you
haven't seen spider-man two i'm totally
ruined for it
but she leaves uh the wedding to go be
with peter and this be from sony maybe
it'll fall down a similar path where she
ends up going i won't get married and
i'm gonna go retreat to eddie brock my
real love but i don't know maybe
that's just a a maybe scenario at this
point and this movie i'm hearing is
going to be
and it seems like it you know like when
they're in the church when the fight
scene is going on there's something that
feels very
ceremonial and there's something that
feels uh like ritualistic
in terms of the kind of performance that
woody harrelson is giving on very
cult-leader like persona
and it's going to be borrowing elements
from the maximum carnage system
feel free to correct me carnage is
essentially using
like homeless people and forming a cult
and it seems like that's kind of the
goal that he's going down not that we
really get
those hits here the trailer that's
ultimately what he's succeeding at like
you have
this sort of natural born killers
element here where
uh him and shriek are like a serial
killer couple to a certain extent the
way he's talking
with eddie brock in this trailer
especially with those last lines you
know
speaking as if like no we should be
family we should be doing this together
it seems like carnage or
cletus has this this this feels like he
has his purpose this cause to go out
there and wreak havoc or
carnage upon the streets and he i feel
like he's gonna be doing a lot of
trying to convince eddie to be on his
side trying to say like
you and i are the same and we should be
doing this together again
helping to keep the you know
entanglement of protagonists and
antagonists that much more
sadistic and rich and engaging and
interesting i mean for yeah so for the
most part it's like this is a pretty
great trailer
i'm sure there's going to be more easter
eggs and stuff that other people will
notice i did not catch but personally
this was awesome i was thoroughly
satisfied well guys leave your thoughts
down below what did you think about this
trailer subscribe click that
notification bell hit that like button
very much appreciate you being here and
i'll catch you guys soon